There are three ways to watch these lectures.
A good way is to kind of watch them and use the Udacity discussion forums
to interact with other people watching these lectures.
Something as better is these lectures are free and the don't really require any books or texts,
but there are books or texts and I would feel really guilty not telling you
that Alexander Osterwalder's "Business Model Generation" book is coming to store book
for understanding the Business Model Canvas and the Startup Owner's Manuel written by yours truly
and my co-author Bob Dorf is kind of a standard for customer development,
but let me emphasized again, these are not required and you can understand the lectures are just fine
without them but they'll surely help explain a lot of the detail in the 617 pages
because it's almost an encyclopedia for startups.
Enough of the ad, that's the last time I'll mention buying the texts or books.
So the best way to watch these lectures is instead of just watching them to do everything above
and also form a startup team and get outside of the building in between watching the lectures
and so you're actually watching the lectures as a guide
for lectures supposed to be doing week to week.
And one of the reasons we've kind of suggest that you instead of just watching the lectures
to actually get out of the building and do it either by yourself or with your team.
The startups are not about lectures, an entrepreneurship is not about your grades
and this class, it's about the work you do outside the building after you watch the lectures--
not how much the lectures you watch.
Entrepreneurship is experience it, it's hands on, and it's immediate and intense feedback.